you would record films but you couldn't
record them you didn't have like a VCR a
cassette to record no I was I was
obsessed with films and at that time my
way of pirating them is when we would
rent movies I would just take like my
tape player and like put it up to the TV
set it just for sound just just to
record the sounds of it so I had all
these movies but you could hear my
parents like cooking dinner in the
background right telling my sister to
shut off in one movie I had done it with
four so for whatever reason was was mr.
mom and I would always like ride around
my neighborhood like this is your mom
sure mom yeah nothing like that yeah I
did
I loved Michael Keith what I was a kid
and then I actually got to meet him on
this movie clear history and I had been
talking to him for about two or three
days and I was like yeah I wonder if it
would be weird if I told him about how
this audio tape of mr. mom and I used to
like listen to it all the time and I
just kind of like went for it like yeah
you know I used to listen to this I'd
drive around my neighborhood with
Walkman on listening to mr. mom and he
just kind of nodded he's heard it all
before
so okay and did you record other movies
too besides mr. mom got older did the
movies did you start recording they've
never got really I mean they're all like
it I have some of them still they're
like hand of they're handwritten I took
it very seriously that in this other
weird Don Knotts movie hot lead and cold
feet I for some reason that was like
whatever I could get I didn't there's
been some phase where you drop that you
just switched over to music I dropped
that and then that was like around
middle school and then it just turned
into like ripping copies of like 2 Live
Crew and eazy-e and like all this dirty
this dirty rap and my parents still
thought I was listening to mr. mom
another and they're like he's really
enjoying mr. mom do we do we need to
listen to mr. mom on the way to church
it's like yeah we do yeah
you